the international banking system is an
enigma there are more than 30,000
different banks worldwide and they hold
unbelievable amounts of assets the top
10 banks alone account for roughly 25
trillion u.s. dollars today banking can
seem very complex but originally the
idea was to make life simpler 11th
century Italy was the center of European
trading merchants from all over the
continent met to trade their goods but
there was one problem too many
currencies in circulation in Pisa
merchants had to deal with seven
different types of coins and had to
exchange their money constantly this
exchange business which commonly took
place outdoors on benches is where we
get the word bank from from the word
Banco Italian for bench the dangers of
travelling counterfeit money and the
difficulty of getting alone got people
thinking it was time for a new business
model horn brokers started to give
credit to businessman while Genoese
merchants developed cashless payments
networks of banks spread all over Europe
handing out credit even to the church or
European Kings what about today in a
nutshell banks are in the risk
management business this is a simplified
version of the way it works people keep
their money in banks and receive a small
amount of interest and the bank takes
this money and lends it out at much
higher interest rates it's a calculated
risk because some of the lenders will
default on their credit this process is
essential for our economic system
because it provides resources for people
to buy things like houses or for
industry to expand their businesses and
grow so banks take funds that are unused
by savers and turn them into funds
society can use to do stuff other
sources of income for banks include
accepting saving deposits the credit
card business and buying and selling
currencies custodian business and cash
management services the main problem
with bang
nowadays is that a lot of them have
abandoned their traditional role as
providers of long term financial
products in favor of short-term gains
that carry much higher risks during the
financial boom most major banks adopted
financial constructs that were barely
comprehensible and did their own trading
in a bid to make first money and earn
their executives and traders millions in
bonuses this was nothing short of
gambling and damaged whole economies and
societies like back in 2008 when banks
like Lehman Brothers gave credit to
basically anyone who wanted to buy a
house and thereby put the bank in an
extremely dangerous risk position this
led to the collapse of the housing
market in the US and parts of Europe
causing stock prices to plummet which
eventually led to a global banking
crisis and one of the largest financial
crises in history hundreds of billions
of dollars just evaporated millions of
people lost their jobs and lots of money
most of the world's major banks had to
pay billions in fines and bankers became
some of the least trusted professionals
the US government and the European Union
had to put together huge bailout
packages to purchase bad assets and stop
the banks from going bankrupt new
regulations were put into force to
govern the banking business compulsory
bank emergency funds were enforced to
absorb shocks in the event of another
financial crisis but other pieces of
tough new legislation were successfully
blocked by the banking lobby to date
other models of providing financing are
gaining ground fast like new investment
banks that charge a yearly fee and do
not get Commission's on sales thus
providing the motivation to act in the
best interests of their clients all
credit unions cooperative initiatives
that were established in the 19th
century to circumvent credit sharks in a
nutshell they provide the same financial
services as banks but focus on shared
value rather than profit maximization
the self-proclaimed goal is to help
members create opportunities like
starting small businesses expanding
farms or building family homes while
investing back into communities they are
controlled by their members who also
elect the
of directors democratically worldwide
credit union systems very significantly
ranging from a handful of members to
organizations worth several billion US
dollars and hundreds of thousands of
members the focus on benefits for their
members impacts the risk credit unions
are willing to take which explains why
credit unions although also hurting
survived the last financial crisis way
better than traditional banks not to
forget the explosion of crowdfunding in
recent years aside from making awesome
video games possible platforms arose
that enable people to get loans from
large groups of small investors
circumventing the bank as a middleman
but it also works for industry lots of
new technology companies started out on
Kickstarter or IndieGoGo the funding
individual gets the satisfaction of
being part of a bigger thing and can
invest in ideas they believe in while
spreading the risks so widely that if
the project fails the damage is limited
and last but not least microcredit
lots of very small loans mostly handed
out in developing countries that help
people escape poverty people who were
previously unable to get access to the
money they needed to start a business
because they weren't deemed worth the
time nowadays the granting of
microcredit has evolved into a
multi-billion dollar business so banking
might not be up your street but the
bank's role of providing funds to people
and businesses is crucial for our
society and has to be done who will do
it and how it will be done in the future
is up for us to decide though
[Music]